and what does Mary Poppins come and do  she comes in and and makes a makes a  mockery of the business of of tidying  the room by using witchcraft uh so  there's no effort expended  um uh violating the natural order of  things and teaching the kids that um uh  they can do their chores without the  effort required and therefore later on  lessons from it she takes them on this  psychedelic Journey teaching them  nonsense words uh she uh Praises Praises  uh  um I mean you you want to know this as  Americans but you don't feed pigeons in  London they're rats with wings that's  what that's what we call them you know  this this lullaby to to send people to  sleep  um is is is is about encouraging  um a Vermin that has destroyed the  architecture of London you know  everything in that movie is about  um undermining or overturning uh the the  natural order of things and this is this  is what uh the  headless selfish prideful mother